el nuevo ministro de exteriores chino
advertido de un choque inminente si
Estados Unidos no pisa el freno ha
señalado Taiwán como el fundamento
elemental de las relaciones bilaterales
y ha defendido el eje Pekín Moscú no hay
nada nuevo en el fondo ni se preveía
pero se esperaba con expectación el
debut de chingan por dos razones primero
porque apenas había habido alusiones a
la agenda internacional en el discurso
inaugural del Primer Ministro
porque del tono de su primera
intervención se puede deducir el tono
que tendrá la diplomacia china en el
futuro cercano y Ching ha hablado claro
advertido de que ese juego imprudente de
Estados Unidos tendrá consecuencias
catastróficas china ha lamentado en los
últimos meses lo que entiende Como una
política hostil de Estados Unidos en
diferentes frentes en las líneas rojas
que cruza en Taiwán en las alianzas
militares en el Pacífico y en la
intensificación de la guerra tecnológica
sin regresa a Pekín después de haber
ejercido como embajador en Estados
Unidos donde se había caracterizado por
un tono sosegado ese cambio en lo alto
del ministerio se entendía como un como
la voluntad de Pekín por rebajar las
tensiones con Estados Unidos
arrinconando a los conocidos Como lobos
Guerreros de la diplomacia muy activos
en las redes sociales y más beligerantes
el Debut permite poner en duda ese
pronóstico el presidente ya había
advertido en la noche anterior que
Estados Unidos está liderando una
coalición en occidente para frenar en la
auge de China